[Music]
well midnight mayhem at the las vegas
motor speedway it's an event for street
enthusiasts to race each other on a
safer turf instead of doing it illegally
in neighborhoods all across the valley
madison kimbrough is live at the
speedway as gates get ready to open in
about an hour madison
yeah the race starts at 6 p.m and it is
first come first serve as you can see we
are here and open to all licensed and
registered street legal vehicles
this legal street racing event has been
hosted by the las vegas speedway for
over a decade a way for drivers to come
on out and race each other in a
structured environment in an attempt to
keep public roadways and neighborhoods
safe within the past couple of years
street racing in the northwest valley
has become extremely prevalent nicole
smith lives in the northwest and says
this event makes a difference it's
keeping them off of the streets of our
neighborhoods and where our people are
walking i think it's great i think it's
positive and it's safe and that's the
number one thing that's on my mind
midnight mayhem organizer jeff foster
says the theatrics in street racing
across the valley have become more of a
thing and there's no need to put others
at risk when this track is available to
them we don't want them out there on the
street racing they want to show how fast
their car goes to their buddy that's
what this is for so we're trying to
bring more of them here and they can do
their burnouts here on the starting line
make a high speed run down the track
there's a 20 fee for drivers with an
additional 15 for passengers and
spectators can watch for five dollars so
far the las vegas motor speedway says
they have 10 of these races scheduled
for this year
and all of these cars are inspected
ahead of time before entering the race
track now we're told that they expect
about 300 cars to show up and 800 to a
thousand spectators tonight reporting
live from the seaway madison kimbrough
live local now
wednesday